[Musique]
le métier de mineur est particulièrement
exigeant pour le corps humain
un chercheur de l'université
laurentienne à sudbury
quand de comprendre pourquoi pour le
savoir il a imaginé une stratégie
surprenante
il amène des mouches à fruits deux
kilomètres sous terre
[Musique]
6h du matin nous sommes à la mine
brighton à sudbury en ontario des
mineurs se prépare à descendre sous
terre dans cette classe hier des
centaines de mouches s'apprête à
descendre aussi du lundi au vendredi
elles vont au boulot comme les mineurs
elle on prend à leur pause café et
remonte à la fin de la journée pour un
repos bien mérité
ce projet et n'hésiter c'est celui du
biologiste comice mérite un expert en
génétique ils espèrent comprendre grâce
au motion
comment le travail super affecte leur
santé des mineurs
la génétique des mouches drosophiles est
étonnamment proche de celle des humains
80% de nos gènes sont identiques et
notre métabolisme est similaire
donc si on comprend ce qui se passe chez
les mouche
on comprend essentiellement ce qui se
passe chez les humains le généticien a
quitté les états unis en 2006 pour
devenir professeur à l'université
laurentienne à sudbury la petite ville
minière a piqué sa curiosité
je m'intéresse à la communauté dans
laquelle je vis est l'essence de sobres
et c'est la mine
le métier de mineur particulièrement
exigeant pour le corps surtout pour ceux
qui travaillent dans une mine
souterraine
lorsqu'on descend sous terre la pression
atmosphérique augmente cette pression
accroît la fatigue on ne comprend pas
exactement pourquoi
que se passe-t-il sur le plan
physiologique
pour trouver la réponse formé ce mérite
ne l'est pas soumettre les mineurs à des
batteries de tests
c'est ici que les mouches entre en scène
elles sont minuscules et elles sont
faciles à manipuler
on peut faire des choses avec elle qu'on
ne ferait jamais avec les humains
l'expérience des buts aux laboratoires
une fois la femelle accoupler ont la
place dans une fiole où elle pendant
quelques centaines de deux semaines plus
tard les oeufs éclosent
on obtient ainsi des récoltes de mouches
qui ont précisément le même âge
[Musique]
les mouches sont placés dans des tubes
de verre la moitié d'entre elles vont
rester à la surface c'est groupe témoin
[Musique]
les autres on prendre un chemin de la
meinau
thomis mérite et son étudiant john rich
pénètre dans l'ascenseur et s'enfonce
sur 2 km
ici la pression atmosphérique et 25 %
plus élevée qu'à la surface les
chercheurs doivent marcher 1,6 km pour
se rendre jusqu'aux os nolan
ce laboratoire est l'un des plus
profonds au moment où il est fréquenté
par des physiciens à la recherche de la
matière sont une composante méconnu
l'univers le généticien a convaincu les
responsables de le laisser y apporter
c'est moche pour ne pas nuire aux
expériences des physiciens temps mais
c'est john doivent se soumettre à une
procédure de décontamination stricte
aucune poussière ne peut entrer à
l'intérieur du laboratoire
maintenant que les mouches sont sous
terre il faut les faire travailler
on veut reproduire le plus fidèlement
possible la journée d'un mineur on met
les mouches sur un tapis roulant
ça ressemble à un grill pour les hot
dogs on couche les fioles sur les
rouleaux et elle tourne pour limoges il
est exact c'est exactement ça à 16h les
mouches remonte à la surface
après cinq jours de labeur le vendredi
et leur dernière journée de travail
c'est le moment fatidique
à la fin de la semaine elle se sacrifie
pour la science on les met dans des
fioles de verre et on les plonge dans
l'azoté liquide pour les congeler la
température de l'azoté liquide et de
moins 196 degrés celsius le métabolisme
des mouches est stoppée net
de retour dans laboratoire l'équipe
pulvérise les mouches pour en faire un
liquide en analyse ensuite la
concentration des métabolites comme le
glucose les lipides ou les acides aminés
à l'intérieur du mélange
les premiers résultats ont montré une
différence significative entre la
concentration de métabolites chez les
mouches qui font du tapis roulant sous
terre et chez celles qui suivent
exactement la même routine à la surface
selon les essais les différences se
chiffre entre 10 et 30%
autrement dit les mouches lorsqu'elles
sont sous terre ne transforme pas les
sucres et les autres éléments essentiels
à la vie à la même vitesse que celles
qui restent à la surface
elles ne produisent pas de l'énergie au
même rythme
[Musique]
les résultats sont encore préliminaires
et les chercheurs doivent pousser les
expériences plus loin pour comprendre
quels mécanismes spécifiques sont en
cause ce qu'on souhaiterait c'est de
pouvoir dire aux compagnies minières
comment elles peuvent créer un
environnement de travail plus sain par
exemple si on découvre que la
métabolisation des protéines et ralenti
sous terre on pourrait suggérer aux
mineurs de réduire leur apport en
protéines
les journées où ils vont travailler
selon tohme ce mérite il n'y a pas que
les mineurs qui pourraient profiter des
résultats de ces recherches
tous les travailleurs qui sont soumis à
des changements de pression pourraient
en bénéficier
j'ai lancé l'idée aux compagnies
aériennes j'adorerais mettre des mouches
à bord de leurs avions
s'il obtient le feu vert ces mouches
pourrait bientôt jouer les agents de
bord